difficile de cacher sa joie à youpougon
commune de la banlieue d'abidjan lé
célèbre maquis sont pris d'assaut
une affluence qui fait suite à
l'allègement des mesures par le
gouvernement avec la levée du couvre-feu
et la réouverture de ces petits bars
restaurants très prisé par les ivoiriens
après presque deux mois de restrictions
une réouverture sous condition du
respect des gestes barrières lavage
régulier des mains port du masque
distanciation physique de moins à m en
fait je veux massivement le gouvernement
d'avoir occasionné cela parce que
vraiment on souffrait si je vais revoir
la copie mardi 19 mai maintenant que
tout en vrai qu'il ya des mesures à
respecter bon je pense que vraiment
c'est bon ou pas passer à l'opération
sur ma bouche et déjà à être continuée
et plus encore la communauté au fait tu
transformes yeux un peu est chez nous ça
donne vraiment pas prévu l'essentiel on
respecte pour aller pouvant les lieux de
spectacles cinémas bars et boîtes de
nuit reste en revanche fermée pour les 5
millions d'habitants de la capitale
économique et sa région
les établissements d'enseignement du
primaire jusqu'au supérieur reprendront
leurs activités eux le 25 mai tandis que
les frontières restent toujours fermés
au moins jusqu'au 31 mai